HAONAD  LGND STAGIN
PREJ AICUDEGASTIN THE RIOEGN
AS A.HO WLE
>> ANWHD ATAP HPENED IN
19,73 BEFRI?LY
>> WL,EL IN 13,97AL S VAAR D
LEALEND WASHRVE ORTNOWY B
AGTOUS SHIEN,DEHE TER GENAL
PPSUBYTEORD  ETHIX N
ONNIADMIONRASTTIUT BT' IS
STMPSILI S TICOT WAYHA
EDPPHAEN IN 13.97
ATWHNEAP HPED TNHE ON
SEBEPTEMR  1TH11,97 W3,AS
JUSTHE TND EUL RESTF O A
OCPRS,ES AIC POL TY,THA
NBEGA IN97 10,H WIT
PRESIDT ENSAL VA DOR
NDALLEE'S EN.CTLEIO
OMFRHE TER VEGY BNIINNG
NI ANXOND KERSIISNG HAD
ATLTCUIVS TEDIEIT WHHE T
ILCHNEA MITILYARND A
ONSPRESOD THE ANAASSSSIONTI
OFER GENALEN REENE SCHERID
IN 10,97 C THEUTSTONITNAIOL
NEGEHEL,RA T OHI CEFFFF STA
OF THEHI CANLEARIL MITY,
USBECAEF O HISCTES RPE FOR
THE PLENCRIIPF OIL MARITY
INBOSURD TIOATNOIV CIAILN
ORAUTHY.IT
ITSO WH HISAS ASSONNASITI,
HIETH CILANLE MARIT GYOT THE
MEAGSSET  THAEYTHOU CLD BE
NEXT USNLESHE TYO TED THE
NELI
.>>OOHE T BSK I NONIX,
INKISSNDRGE ALL ADEEN, A
UNCO IN CEEMIOMTT
.>>AL RPH NERADES D
IBCREDGEGEORUS BASH  THE MOST
PEIMBLACHAERE PDESI INTN
STHINDYOR AO TY MAN
ANERAMIC OSURVENT IERIONTN
IINRAMS SQEEFUT O OHE T
OR ANADIRYND TY'HERE
EDPAAPLLY B BHUSO ALS
PO BEDLLSY TUTHEAC SPHT IF
WEEA RD MYK BOOE' WLL
IZREALT TEHANW UEDRAARNT
INTEENRVONTI OSRSVESEARE A
PA ORTF AIS HRITOLCAAT PRNTE
HEON TAR PT OFAS WNNGHITO.
>>